we live I think we live hey Batman
Beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard
we're back kids and I mean this is like
an important show it really is yeah
there was like a like do we do a show
this week and then they dropped the
[ __ ] news more like how are we not
doing a show the show was originally
called fat man on Batman so Batman was
part of our Charter absolutely they
dropped some [ __ ] huge Batman news
today kids and we're gonna talk about
that in one minute just a what did it
called disclaimer in advance I got to go
home for the 10 o'clock viewing a airing
of celebrities show off the show that
I'm working on on TBS so we're gonna
keep this like tight if it doesn't go on
for hours as per usual that's the only
reason but before we dive into the news
and stuff and we know what the news is
how are you I'm good certainly have
enough time to check in on old friends
how are you hello old chum I'm good
I'm mark just gave me mine [ __ ] ly
good news that we can't even share not
for months no and but like [ __ ] and
this would be the show to break that
[ __ ] talk to the people about it when
it's time but still it's like right
before we went in this all casual way
like the way by the way like the way
he'd be like oh I had pizza today and it
was good oh really
welcome to the show but instead it was
like [ __ ] needle scratching news
that's very very [ __ ] cool when do
you think we'll be able to tell or
you'll be all the time I instantly
glommed on to marks glory King when will
we tell you about your good idea I am
not entirely sure it's a thing that just
literally materialized overnight like
papers still need to be signed if work
needs to be done before anybody feels
comfortable announcing anything but it
is pretty cool that's dope got anything
going on in your life no I'll go the
plague nerdy logs the plague dead logs
go incredibly well last week we we had
lin-manuel Miranda's swinging from the
[ __ ] top rope yeah which one did he
do he did commander William Adama from
the Battlestar Galactica miniseries Wow
he kept calling them captain Adama and I
wasn't gonna correct him like whatever
you want man you said yes but he's like
you know what not correcting me that's
how you stay in the room where it
happens that's why I stay in your room
where you want things to happen oh my
lord Wow
what's the connection I get up for this
[ __ ] show if he ever does a [ __ ]
fantasy thing he's well he did that at
HBO show what is it called his dark
material yeah which we never talked
about cuz none of us ever saw or cared
that much well now we could if he's
coming on our show have a good watch
I've seen it all he cried oh yeah
probably throw that out there like Babe
Ruth pointing to the [ __ ] left or
right field like probably gonna happen
yeah Wow I you know I interviewed him
for the LA Times when I was there but
Moana and and then like he we started
following each other well I was
following him to be fair much earlier
than he was following me on the
Twitter's I remember the police were
alarmed they were what and then I just
literally [ __ ] I decided to shoot my
shot and I made my shot count and I was
slit up in his DMS and I was like hey
man I got this charity thing I know
you've got like a thousand different
things pulling at you and you're raising
money for 15 different organizations and
I get it but here's what this is if
you've got the time of inclination and
you're interested let me know if not no
harm no foul whatsoever I get it and
like two weeks later he's like [ __ ] I'm
sorry I missed this I'd like to do a
dhama and I said yes and this was like a
Friday he's like I'll get over to you by
Sunday okay
and then he had it to me Sunday night
how do you how do you [ __ ] not open
with that that's crazy like you waited
till we're ten minutes and you're like
by the way zip lin-manuel on my payroll
wow that's awesome
yeah and so we went we launched the
second wave and we raised like 20 grand
in a
and a half and then the week after like
Lin shows up and now we're up at 43
thousand dollars I think and it's still
steamed along and we still got new ones
coming out all the time we got one from
andre royo who played bubbles from the
wire mmm you think I want to do one that
yes you can do one absolutely you I'm
not gonna say no bubbles wants to do one
and it's pretty great
he has a gun up yet he hasn't gotten up
yet he'll go up there you don't say
Wednesday Thursday yeah name is spoiler
although it is superhero adjacent really
it is yeah from the list or have you had
anybody be like I got one I want to do
that's no no this was him he was like I
want to do this one serious look yeah
it's like yes oh so that's passion right
there yeah for sure like a night
something tells me he already knew it
really yeah like the way you know the
[ __ ] dune thing because I like I told
you I couldn't memorize for [ __ ] and
it's astonishing to me that these dudes
can just especially Lynn so I got for
you like in two days memorized it how do
you do it it's me dude [ __ ] right
Hamilton you all the words true good boy
[ __ ] wait a way to diminish the guys
tell me oh yeah it it hounds him I wrote
in words like they're your course he had
an edge that's [ __ ] tremendous yeah
so that's all I got other than our
apparent ability to see into the future
yeah which is elitist into the news and
leading us into the news mark was a news
man as he previously mentioned and today
his services are called upon for the
biggest [ __ ] news this news made me
so [ __ ] happy and I'm just gonna
focus on the positive but I do want to
say I couldn't believe there was a
single negative tweet about this and yet
I saw somebody be like I don't like it I
was like [ __ ] you Internet they finally
give us something nice and shiny and
good and still there's somebody to [ __ ]
on I knew that internet wasn't to be
trusted the moment I read back in like
1998 somebody said Quentin Tarantino's a
hack and I was like look if there's
anything I know to be not true it's that
that dudes a [ __ ] hack I
disagree with his internet in general
and then I get brought into it and I
gave it to see my trust back and then
they ruined it with that [ __ ] tweet
who could not be happy about this news
let's tell them what the news is or
should we go in the Wayback Machine
let's do that let's do that Oh
a younger version of ourselves kids when
was this this was November 2017 it's
[ __ ] oh my god
yeah it was that no idea 2020 was coming
oh [ __ ]
like it had already gotten a little bit
bad cuz like there's still hope though
there's maybe a little bit of hope but
we were reviewing Justice League I think
either the actual movie itself or the
trailer or something but uh but yeah and
so we we spun we waxed rhapsodic as
we're known to do and we apparently
dropped this little 1-minute nugget that
that is somewhat prognostic this is like
us being The Simpsons
yes Batman Beyond predicted it here we
go let's hear it and ironically like
flash flashpoint gives you the
opportunity for that reset or crisis
gives you the opportunity for that reset
well they should lean into the flash buh
I mean I know they've had a hard [ __ ]
time putting the flash movie together
but now that you see that that element
could work like give asthma Miller a
flashpoint movie that's there you go
that's an exact way to correct your
entire DC no I mean what DC has a Marvel
does and a great story a warm story a
story about a child's love for a parent
gone wrong and [ __ ] like that like
there's real heart to that story and it
plays with time and throughout the DC
Universe you do a lot of [ __ ] cool
things with that I mean and they have a
multiverse Marvel doesn't have a
multiverse there's a world in which if
you do a crisis story then you can have
Michael Keaton Christian Bale
digital at Adam West you can have all of
these [ __ ] Batman's together
stop making better movies than these
[ __ ] people oh my god you need to be
in charge what a good [ __ ] idea I can
pick I'll show you [ __ ] everybody's mind
though like guess what
[ __ ] Marvel we're connecting all the
movie
michael keaton exists with [ __ ] ben
affleck with george clooney whoa Wow
I mean you predicted the future has made
a lot of jokes about it but my god well
done Wow and it's kind of what that
smells like they're doing it is what it
smells like they're doing because that
the big news of the week is Michael
Keaton is in active negotiations with
Warner Brothers to reprise his role as
The Dark Knight Bruce Wayne for the
flash in any other year that would be
the biggest news that [ __ ] happen
like UFOs are real Keaton is Bacchus
Batman but being 20/20 ppit's it's not
it doesn't penetrate it as far as I
would like it to although it was all
over the Internet it really was people
we're so happy about it it is one of
those things that again how can you find
a problem with Michael Keaton returning
and also like man to go from DC to
Marvel back to DC and the indications
are they're going to make Michael
Keaton's Batman like Samuel Jackson next
year Nick Fury so he's kind of like a
mentor there setting it up for Batman
Beyond and it sounds like their version
of Batman Beyond is Batman mentoring
Batgirl as opposed to Terry McGinnis
that's definitely a where to go I mean a
definitely way that makes a ton of
[ __ ] sense but oh my god like I mean I
was gonna say could you did you ever
think and apparently you did but that is
it don't you feel like listened to and
also by the way I would point out that
that clip predates spider-verse you kind
of described what would eventually
happen in spite yes because I did say
Marvel doesn't have a multiverse and
like that's I was wrong there I was they
do have a multiverse we're about to see
Doctor Strange and the more universe of
madness they found their way into it but
but yeah I guess Warner Brothers owes me
money
keya I'll tell you who they're gonna
know money is Michael Keaton yes what do
you pay for that kind of service that is
not gonna be a cheap deal but much
because they're talking about multiple
movies like it's not just the flash it's
not just maybe Batgirl like he can be
the connective tissue if they ever make
a cyborg movie never gonna happen but
anything's anything's possible possible
I mean they could look and drop him in
Justice League because did you see that
there's there's a rumor today I caught
it just before I left that Ryan Reynolds
is negotiating to cameo in Zack Snyder's
Justice League are you [ __ ] me yeah
yeah I mean here
why wouldn't he you know what I'm saying
reason not to he's richer and Roosevelt
is fun he's Canadian like that's just a
good idea he likes a good time yeah [ __ ]
that smart I support that I hope he does
do that that would be so cool that'd be
even cooler for Zach because that wasn't
a part of their plans I don't believe it
was now but man you want to make a noise
you know what happened what do they do
in the like Pinocchio's and [ __ ] like
that what's the opposite of Pinocchio's
where you if you were doing something
where you're like I [ __ ] cosign the
story that sound that really babbles
like truth that sound like it's such
great speculation but it sounds
absolutely believable to me yeah and it
makes it makes sense because especially
because he's been very kind of sage
about his relationship to Green Lantern
which was not a well-received movie did
not do extraordinarily well at the box
office but wasn't like a flop but
there's no real love for that iteration
of Green Lantern no but it did [ __ ]
provide a hell of a joke and Deadpool
absolutely like it didn't have to like
he could have steered clear it's
basically a 200 million dollar setup for
a fantastic punch line in a 50 million
dollar really he's reading the script
for greens like I think this is a great
idea what is it don't make it green that
is spellbinding [ __ ] news brought me
right back to my childhood
today there's ago 31 years ago Batman
debuted in theatres Tim Burton's Batman
I was sitting there talking to my wife
earlier this evening let's go [ __ ] what
time is it and she's like I don't know
when we looked it was 4 o'clock and I
was like somewhere in the [ __ ]
streams of time 31 years from this
moment and I'm in New Jersey leaving
Domino's forever even though I'd only
worked there for like three four hours
and going to see Batman with like Brian
Walton stuff today's the 31st
anniversary of Batman coming out so
Michael Keaton Batman news incredibly
welcomed on this day smart idea like and
you know I know everyone's always like
they ain't got a Kevin Feige over there
somebody had to come up with this idea
yeah there's some but not like some
accountant or some lawyer going like I
think people would like this like if
somebody had to put the creative
somebody's listening to our [ __ ] show
is what it sounds like
I would man if I was a studio I'd listen
to the show it's like a bunch of free
[ __ ] ideas which we should stop doing
I've been told we should stop doing I
know but this is a good one like like we
couldn't have affected this it's not
like you and we got enough money to hire
Michael Keaton to be our back yeah so
like that's an idea you can throw away
for free what you don't [ __ ] throw
away for free is the Cinderella [ __ ]
story still smarten about it Michael
Keaton here's what I can do for you I
can buy you a thousand chicken nuggets
cuz Burger Kings got them on sale 10 for
$10 I will spend $100 to get you a
thousand chicken nuggets
well that gets you to be back Warner
Brothers goes beat yeah they got also
it's an odd chicken nugget money we
don't we can't even burn out their
prefer gold where I'm them on the Nugget
I'm on the Nugget standard yeah
do you think he in a billion [ __ ]
years when he was like no I'm not gonna
do this anymore and walked away or is
that what that's what happened right he
was yeah because they came to him they
were like do it here's more money it's
like I want to do this anymore yeah I'm
done I did two of these I'm good do you
think ever yeah even when he was playing
[ __ ] vulture yeah do like when he's
[ __ ] on it kind of in Birdman it was
like this you guys there never
asking me back after this and yet oh my
god
mr. Douglas would you like to be Batman
again
[Laughter]
look my Michael Keaton or Michael
Douglas is incredibly talented we'll
never take that away from him
I love mr. mom what if it negotiated go
bad and they literally go to Michael
Douglas yeah and he's like I'm suddenly
Batman how that happened I'm so no I'm
pimp I'm him over there he is a talented
man I'm taking nothing away from him but
how [ __ ] lucky is that that like he's
lat he's still around mhm and [ __ ]
Batman still around long enough we're
[ __ ] three decades on almost and [ __ ]
is it three literally three decades on
for the first time he strapped on those
rubber tights and [ __ ] they're like you
want to go again you be [ __ ] lucky to
get asked to be Batman once in this
lifetime but to be asked back and then
be like not only you're coming back for
like you know it's not like good thing
he held out on crisis I'll say that much
right because you know that [ __ ] Marc
Guggenheim was probably like we got to
get Michael Keaton come on full-court
press can we get Keaton and Michael
Keaton people are like don't move don't
move give them wool yeah throw rubber
will at them we got we got we got a
larger play here oh my god it's such a
good it does seem like the kind of idea
maybe an agent went to a studio with
rather than a studio come to them right
and also the fact that Michael Keaton is
still viable enough for it to be a real
get like as if it's like hey you know
what we're doing Cannonball Run 3 we
can't do without Dom DeLuise and like
granted he's dead I understand that but
like that idea of we're working on the
McNugget currency still here it's
standard so obviously DeLuise references
[ __ ] play but like kids Dom DeLuise
was a comedian once about a time of a
loved' character actor many years ago he
only he only died fairly recently really
I think so somebody look it up like I
remember like it was one of those things
where I'm like what like that 2008
really still kick yeah I bet you it
might be in that maybe correct me if I'm
wrong somebody
somebody looking it up JC's got his head
in his hands like they're talking about
DeLuise again then nobody's gonna come
to this bar if they talk about double-a
blood the bar we are
when 2009 I would have swore he died in
like 1992 right 75 what a legend in any
event like Mark was saying you can't
make this movie without Dom DeLuise so
Warner Brothers I know Michael Keaton's
gonna cost you a pretty penny but
getting DeLuise mess could cost you
everything you got to get some of that
ILM volume you had to go work in we've
built the DeLuise in the matrix here he
is hello I can't do it's been so long I
can't remember my as if I ever had a
back pocket Dom DeLuise impression
it is crazy crazy cuckoo nuts that we
live in this world where Michael
Keaton's putting the [ __ ] cow back on
indeed I mean and look we live in the
ironman world where he didn't put the
outfit on by the end of those movies if
you know what my headin game lady's
wearing his [ __ ] pajamas know like
we'll put the suit on later go ahead
just smile and say funny things yeah
it's all the glasses just say I am Iron
Man in snow so it could be that Michael
Keaton's like I'm never getting in a
rubber suit again no because it
literally was rubber and Batman Returns
remember he rips the mask at the end huh
Mike is not a [ __ ] even [ __ ] is
this
yeah I mean if he's playing you know
Bruce Wayne from Batman Beyond like he
doesn't wear the outfit he's [ __ ]
black suit in the turtleneck that's an
idea we supported here on this show as
well we were talking about like Michael
Keaton they should get him to play
Batman Beyond man well [ __ ] there did
and I'm just happy that exists and it's
not confirmed right it's a rumor but it
seems pretty a lot of sources all of
those had no comment but it ran in The
Hollywood Reporter and they and
everybody picked it up and they are not
ones to just for real just like we heard
from a guy right they have to have some
real source and Entertainment Weekly
wrote about it yeah and they might you
know aren't they still part of Time
Warner yeah yeah so they might as well
now that's they're out yes everybody
gets old
so they're no longer part of the family
yeah oh it seems true I'm just gonna
[ __ ] look I need it to be true that's
all I'm saying
yeah I don't have much else going on
right now so [ __ ] I need that to be this
is my officer to gentleman moment makes
me so happy man it makes me happy that
I've lived long enough that I survived
that [ __ ] heart attack to live in a
world where the like you're getting heat
one more time one more time Cal him all
right so that's the news [ __ ] everything
else else worth talking about that is is
everything man yeah that is the big news
now the first place he might pop up and
this is where the news kind of broke was
in the flash movie right which is
supposed to start production
well [ __ ] we're supposed to start this
spring well that's over yeah so whenever
production gets back up and running
whenever people's deals start to make
and this is Andy machete driver did it
yeah so like they got a director they
apparently have the script that they
like and now they got [ __ ] Michael
Keaton and we'll see if Ezra Miller is
not toxic anymore after he convention in
in Reykjavik yeah yeah I'm quiet since
then yeah yeah but looks like that
movies happenin regardless it does and
I'm surprised that it is because I had
19 directors who kind of came and went
but if you're gonna spend the money on
Keaton then you're making a movie yeah
and also like it gives you a sense of
like purpose and direction and vision
beyond like what you're doing in the
immediate yeah man I'm on I'm on board
this is awesome this could be it like
I'm not gonna say like this could turn
things around for Warner Brothers
they're doing quite well they're you
know they're Joker Aquaman [ __ ]
Wonder Woman like they're doing great
they don't need any turnaround help that
being said you know with everybody kind
of being mad about like you know what
they've done with Snyder verse and
whatnot although that's what I saw
like the negative I saw were people
going like
I want I don't want Michael Keaton I
want Ben Affleck can you see Michael
Keaton fighting Margot Robbie Robbie
Robbie Robbie thank you
you know I well I mean I hate to be this
guy but it wouldn't be Michael Keaton
fighting Margot Robbie it'd be a stunt
guy so you're never gonna see that but
maybe some close-ups or something but is
that the idea will he be in that world I
continuity I mean I don't know how far
they're going with the flash point of it
all and how much they're gonna actually
intersect the currents not averse into a
flash point verse or whatever you I
think they just claim everything I mean
kind of like what crisis did just claim
it a home be like it all happened and
she throughout the multiverse even
[ __ ] Adam West especially Adam West
yeah but like there is absolutely the
world in which Michael Keaton's Batman
would at that age would never be the I'm
gonna get out there and [ __ ] punch
you in the face exactly he's an old man
I'm the greatest detective in the world
I'm the third smartest person on the
planet like I got this without ever
lifting a finger I got to tell you man
like it makes me excited like I don't
get me wrong of course I love Ben but
like Michael Keaton was like my Batman
you know what I'm saying like when when
Tim Burton's Batman came out for the
first time you were like good lord like
they did it he's dark like which is
weird because you watch the movie now
and you're like dork but darker than we
were used to instead lot of Brits but
like we're gonna see him do that
performance again one of my favorite
moments in movie history is that shot
from Batman Returns were the [ __ ]
mirrors reflect the bat-signal and he
stands up into it and [ __ ] like it's so
stupid and hokey but beautiful and
wonderful yeah and like it's a comic
book
and that's exactly what what about thank
God nobody's standing around [ __ ]
Wayne Manor going there's an awful lot
of reflective lights pointing in that
one window what's all these mirrors for
who's the Alfred you think ain't gonna
be Michael go no well I mean it could be
[ __ ] Michael Caine again if you
wanted to be it could be Jeremy Irons
again if you wanted it to be oh no or or
he's
because if Bruce Wayne is that old maybe
Alfred's yeah Bruce Wayne is [ __ ]
pushing money circus who's playin now
Fred in the Batman but they said those
bet that Matt Reeves the Batman is not
tied into this world I love house
fighting like something I have no skin
and no no no Marsh they can't do that
you like my Batman look why of course
they can do whatever they want maybe
well it would make sense if you've got
Michael Keaton as the older Bruce Wayne
that he is now Alfred and right Batgirl
or young Batman Beyond or whatever where
you see him at this funeral for Alfred
like you opened with him at the funeral
at the graveside as they're burying
Alfred Pennyworth didn't I tell you that
I cried enough watch him go in Ted you
really try to make me cry right on
camera that's [ __ ] good don't give
that [ __ ] away it's not mine to give do
what they're gonna do they already took
[ __ ] Michael Keaton that's true
that's true
they take everything that's good
is there any other news well there's
other bad news but it's not good bad
news yeah that was that was the big
shiny thank god world hear news it was a
bit of ironic timing as well it was as
sort of Michael Keaton is not like
Alanis Morissette hey that's fun ironic
it's a tie Saturdays Michael Keaton
straps back on and into the cowl perhaps
we had a pair of Batman related passings
since we last gathered again my god
you're right there been - there been -
the first of which was Denny O'Neil who
was a longtime comic book writer and
editor works for both Marvel and DC and
then Marvel again in DC again but you
know he passed away at 81 but he worked
on Batman and the question and Green
Arrow and Green Lantern and and he is
most lauded I think for bringing a sense
of social realism and social awareness
to DC when Marvel always was steeped in
it Marvel being in the real world
in Hell's Kitchen and dealing with
things like you know drugs and alcohol
and prostitution and the evils of New
York and what what that does to people
DC had never quite been about that but
denny o'neil was one of the first to
actually start bringing that to the
forefront mmm and having characters like
Green Lantern actually wrestled with the
ideas like oh you're saving lots of
people in the in the galaxy and you're
out you know whatever didn't like ice
night in darkest whatever it's very
another very famous from hard traveling
heroes and they encounter an
african-american gentleman who's like
you helped the yellow man and the purple
man and the green man but what about
right here on earth and the black man
yeah and our heroes have a moral crisis
of conscience
inde and kind of disrobe and go
traveling across america encountering
not like super villains like Starro and
[ __ ] but like real issues it was a big
deal when they still considered seminal
work for DC and Denny was also the guy I
mean he wrote an amazing run on the
question with Dennis Cowan's our [ __ ]
one of my favorite runs of comics ever
Danny also largely responsible for
returning Batman to the Dark Knight
detective he was born you know kind of
the Dark Knight detective and then of
course during the Adam West run and
sixties Batman got a lot more campy
throughout his comic book run when Denny
O'Neill took the character over in the
early 70s mid 70s at that point that was
when he kind of returned the character
to the shadows more not the smiley
Batman went away in the Batman that
everyone still knows today the Dark
Knight Detective driven my parents were
killed that guy became the prevalent
Batman he Denny was responsible for that
yeah and like Neal Adams was the artist
on his you know the beginnings and they
were like thieves and so that Neal Adams
Batman is for lots of people the
definitive Batman and the dude writing
that Batman was
you know and when he was at Marvel he
was also an editor and he hired a thin
sort of strapping young upstart named
Frank Miller to work on there to work on
daredevil you know and and basically a
started his career and as a writer and
an artist like he let him have that
latitude when pencil errs didn't have
that kind of freedom to stretch that's
true UB started as a penciler on
daredevil yeah and then he was given
script one one month and then he stayed
on the book as the writer yeah and like
basically turned daredevil into the
character you know today that was his
test run on Batman before Frank Miller
went and redefined Batman with the Dark
Knight Returns he had this like
wonderful run on daredevil which was
essentially his ramp up for when he got
to deal with the bat right and then when
Danny went over to DC he then brought
Frank over and like that's Danny edited
Batman you want yeah you know which
again sort of ground zero for again a
new generation of the Batman that that
fans would come to know and love that's
true how weird he was the guy that
redefined Batman and then he brought in
the next guy who redefined Batman again
yeah
a lovely man he we did he was on this
very show or the original incarnation
the show fat man on Batman and we did
many our episode I think it was like
three separate episodes which we just
put up when Danny passed we put them all
together and put them up online for
everyone to listen it's a four-hour show
or something like that but never boring
because he was not a boring guy the the
bat bard the chairman emeritus all
[ __ ] class man if there's a Mount
Rushmore of Batman riders he's
definitely one of the faces up there for
sure yeah and now he he's elsewhere man
I was lucky to have sat down with the
man met him his work influenced me I
still loved like a lot of his stories
still hold the same power and impact
they had for me when I first read them
but because of what I do in life I was
lucky enough to get to sit down and pick
his brain for a while and tell him the
[ __ ] that I loved and stuff and we put
him on an episode of comic book
as well so uh wonderful man and and we
were lucky that we had him to tell the
stories for as long as we did
he was the storyteller a particularly
our childhood I mean the man worked
right up to the end but in terms of us
growing up and the influences we had and
like comics we were reading the stories
that captured our imaginations Denny was
one of our storytellers so it's always
sad to see any pro go at any age and
Denny was up there how old was 80 80
years old but you know sadder when it's
somebody whose work influenced you still
impacts I'll never forget there's a page
and I think it's question number five or
six like Vic's age he's reinventing the
character he made it a character a lot
more relatable than the Aisne Randian
version that originally existed and
stuff but he's got this one moment where
the question you know he wrote these
characters that are rebels against
impossible odds let's go there's one
moment where like all the [ __ ]
gangsters in Hub City are surrounding
the question you know he's got the
no-face and everything like that and
they're like what are you gonna do now
and he's like cut to a panel of him he's
like I'm gonna beat all of you and he
doesn't but it was just that certainty
there like in the face of danger like
this is what I'm gonna accomplish so
good yeah he was a magician he was a
wordsmith and he gave us a lot of cool
things to do when we were kids we'll
miss him yes he will be sorely missed
but left a huge footprint in pop culture
a huge bucket a win as we say over on
Hollywood babble-on good night Danny
thank you speaking of a huge footprint
in pop culture in a slightly different
way but no no less important Joel
Schumacher yes
this is the ironic news because just as
Michael Keaton returns his Batman Joel
Schumacher who took over when Michael
Keaton left when he and Tim Burton left
and he did Batman Forever and Batman and
Robin passed away mm-hmm 80 years old
yeah okay I met him once back over the
course of the time I've been this
business when I was writing on Superman
lives they said hey we're shooting
Batman and Robin on the lot you want to
go and I was like yeah [ __ ] yeah so I
went it was the day that they were
showing Joel the brand-new Batmobile for
Batman and Robin what a lovely man yeah
so sweet courteous gossipy as hell loved
gossip like years and I think that's why
he liked me because I was incredibly
candid and he was just very into that he
was the one you know many people have
heard the cradle the balls work the
shaft story he told me that story was
where I heard it first and I had just
met the man so sit down kid your name is
let me tell you he loved like to chat
like he was a director who hosted the
movie like sappy on the monitor and and
helped court so while people were
building the shot or whatever keeping
people entertained and stuff like that
really nice nice man you know that movie
is what that movie is but that man made
a lot of great flicks he did that we
enjoy saying almost fire being one of
them Flatliners being another one leader
wrote the [ __ ] Wiz which is weird
because he before that he was like what
production designs a costume design
costume designer he created maybe where
the gossip comes from perhaps yes he a
grenade from a department nobody ever
connects with directing you know nobody
ever goes well if you want to be a
director one day it all starts the
costume department so that dude
aggregated from that department all the
way up to directing I think his first
movie was the first directing was the
incredible shrinking woman with Lily
Tomlin which was a huge cable movie when
I first got cable I saw the movie so
many [ __ ] times it's all HBO had yeah
it was like they're one of nine movies
they played over and over a falling-down
as you mentioned with with Michael
Keaton and or Michael Douglas can't
remember I don't want DC cab
that's right yeah so he worked with mr.
t and Bill Maher he did he also and I
remember this got surfaced in in the
wake of his passing he did his great
interview with I want to say it was New
York Magazine where like the the bit
that gets shared a lot is he claims to
have slept with over 20,000 men are you
[ __ ] me
no that's like he's the Wilt Chamberlain
of like gay film directors you know Wilt
Chamberlain claimed to have slept with
everybody that Joel Schumacher didn't
see her I remember I heard that he had
very large numbers but yeah really that
was one thing that he did not share with
me on set that day no did he try to
sleep with you no because if you hit
that number you're basically taking
every shot you get I mean I gotta be
honest with you after hearing 20,000 it
makes you go like I wonder why now I'm
curious does it seem like a
discriminating yeah call me curious
though by me and that's that's a lot
that's like McDonald's like you know 20
billion served no no that's a life's
work
I mean Eddie made movies you know me
like on this side it would take a long
time to have sex with 20,000 people even
if you had no job and he had a job that
requires a lot of different people it's
true now that I think about it I haven't
and I did math on this I have not even
had sex with my wife 20,000 times it's
like are you sure 20,000 not two
thousand twenty thousand men this has
claimed now there could have been group
instances I mean what like a group of
five thousand how do you get to 20 yeah
like a Spruce Goose full of dudes like
maybe I don't know I was getting ready
to give the man like I really like sweet
send-off and he'll still get it but now
I want to talk about is how much [ __ ]
D he was pulling that's insane yeah no
he was uh he was he was a cocksman
if ever there was one [ __ ] makes you
feel unaccomplished doesn't it and so I
don't think I've ever done anything
20,000 times maybe taking a breath yeah
I got up maybe it was a sometimes true
[ __ ] man good for him yeah oh my god he
[ __ ] sucked the marrow out of life
didn't he literally
figured I mean Jesus he made a lot what
over the other movies I know we're
missing something
all right let's see bees oh the client
which I [ __ ] love a client finna be
up he worked at Tommy Lee Jones a couple
times Flatliners flawless eight million
Wallace yeah wonderful [ __ ] film
Philip Seymour Hoffman oh so good
trespass phone booth phone booth Colin
Farrell one whole movie in a phone booth
yep which by the way sidebar I watched
on Amazon his movie called seventy five
hundred with John Joe gordon-levitt his
name just press play press play Joe
whatever drank hit record thank you I
knew it sounded [ __ ] yeah record Joe hit
wrecked Joe it's a movie called seventy
five hundred and it's about a hijacking
honestly [ __ ] like gripping ninety
minutes really yes I don't want to ruin
its litter it's a hijacking almost in
real time and he's the guy up in the in
the in the cockpit and there's some [ __ ]
that happens where you're like holy [ __ ]
like you just sit there going what would
I do and that kind of like Air Force one
no this is real this is more like like
good off on my plane yeah none of that
[ __ ] it's it's like it's pretty bloody
and pretty harrowing pretty scary but
one of the most gripping sequences in
the movie it's so [ __ ] weird is
something that we all used to take for
granted and still will when we go back
to you've flown once about a time you've
twenty thousand times in terms of like
you know they say taking off and landing
or two most dangerous times you know
where the pilots have to be on and [ __ ]
there's a sequence in the movie where
they have to land a plane and it's
honestly like one of the most gripping
[ __ ] sequences I've seen in a movie
in ten years where I was like everyone
shut the [ __ ] up like and it wasn't even
like tons dialogue all the dialogue was
technical just about like how one you
know slow it down to 45 knots or just
collapsed 12 degrees literally but it
was so well made that I was like holy
[ __ ] like it they even took the landing
of a plane to a [ __ ] intense place
worth watching particularly we gotta
Amazon Prime's [ __ ] freak anyways
back to
yeah now he had an incredibly wild and
varied career nice dude by all report I
mean other than the time I met him I
hurt other people yeah nobody ever had a
complain about it no I think he was he
was what they used to call an actor's
director and you know he made them feel
comfortable he got the best work out of
them he indulged them to sort of chase
their muses and always gave them a safe
space to work in mmm as opposed to being
a somewhat more cinematic dictator
exists and gets amazing work out of
people you know he was yeah I like to
think of those as movie hosts the
director as hosts it's something in the
beginning of my career I didn't
understand now I understand it way more
where it's just like it's a party and
you invited everybody so host them no
don't be elusive over in the corner
being I'm directing like [ __ ] hey man
how are you guess what we're doing today
like it's a [ __ ] circus so yeah he
was he's definitely in my in my
directorial DNA for that because I
remember watching him on set that day
I'm being like this God does the job way
different he that's literally what it
was like the dude was having like a
[ __ ] blast he seemed to have a fun
life man good dude yeah and you know
like and I remember seeing a lot of
people kind of reexamining and
reappraising because he took a bullet
well he took the bullet on Batman and
Robin like he went out there one day and
was like it's bad movie I'm sorry and
fandom took that like seriously were
like well he apologized
who knew was that [ __ ] simple no I
had a [ __ ] I'd have been over Yoga
those are years ago if I just came out
was like I'm sorry I was wrong maybe not
but they did reconsider him they did and
they reconsidered those movies and be
honest with you he didn't seem to give a
[ __ ] no he doesn't really but anymore he
didn't then he wasn't like you know my
critics I mean put it everything and
it's a proper perspective I'll tell you
he can't give a [ __ ] he probably didn't
read any criticism because he was busy
whenever he wasn't on set notching those
numbers it was insane
Deandra did you cosign that from over
there 20,000 yeah at least he says 20
20,000 is
400 per year for 50 years non-stop to
get to 20,000 so that's more than and he
was 81 one day yeah so let's say all
right but let's dial him back let's say
he started at 20 so let's give him 60
years of [ __ ] do the math 60 years
into 20,000 this is important [ __ ] and
this is why you tune into the show this
is why Kevin's gonna be late you know
what I'm saying
TBS has two wigs we have to figure this
out this is the big news I'm Michael
King likes a Batman who knew I never
heard this 333 so here you take like one
month a year off essentially cause it's
up February one day a month right there
you can take Sundays off from [ __ ]
people six days a week
Wow like you know in this [ __ ] 70s in
New York Plato's retreat like that dude
just wall-to-wall I know but even even
had an orgy like I mean I've never been
to one so I can't speak from experience
but based on movies I've seen you know
like what was the Tom Cruise movie where
everyone's wearing masks and they got
kings and their [ __ ] eyes wide shut
right eyes wide shut let's say that's
the party how many what 10 times if
you're lucky 10 different sexual
partners and then that's their like it's
it's 5:00 in the morning go home like
well it also depends on what you were
considering slept with now is that just
literally putting a pole in a hole or is
that like going all the way to
completion
excellent point it's true I'm just
saying it's totally possible it's like I
had 100 dudes last night what happened
yes no no no no no no yes like when I
heard this news today I was sad because
I was like [ __ ] like I wish I'd gotten
him on the show like just to talk about
I thought that sense was going to dive
heard that but now I would have loved to
have talked to him about a lot of things
now that I hear that oh talking about
the movies and I would have been like 20
come on 20k I'll give you ten I'll splat
you ten you know I mean you could spot
me 19
and a half and I still wouldn't be climb
hundred different people
I can we give JC a shot real quick bless
you for doing that [ __ ] math man haha
I'm big come on nobody asked for it and
still you were like by the way in order
to accomplish this impossible feat one
would have to [ __ ] more than 300 times
just a bar owner he's [ __ ] map to EF
Hutton when he talks we listen Wow who
knew I think I'm [ __ ] you learn a lot
about people when they pass away 20,000
people knew I know with 20,000 people
one of them might have been my dad you
know what I'm saying like those odds
they get real close to home I know I
wasn't one of them believe me I would
share it right now but like a decent
chunk of eastern seaboard spend time in
New York
good for him [ __ ] I mean guys look I
mean look never-ending O'Neil was
wonderful and of course a huge bucket of
win but like this is a huge crater of
wind this man just lived [ __ ] life
anytime I felt bad were people like went
after his movies out the window no he
didn't he didn't care used to busy
[ __ ] somebody poor or working on it
cuz got it it seems like a lot of work
how many three 30 40 years 60 years
excuse me 60 years I'm like I'm about to
turn 50 I'm getting tired of [ __ ] now
this guy's got me by 30 years and he
kept going like he deserves a pension
for this no he should give one for the
DGA yes and then one from the oh my god
joel god bless you man
you deserve that rest and blah [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] work oh my god
he was busy easier than we knew and Wow
I mean somebody else died but I mean who
else
what you got yeah I mean what did they
do yes
Ian's home let's bring it down Sir Ian
Holm passed away he was an alien and he
was of course Bilbo he wasn't know how
many people he had sex with mark by any
chance one of those interviews was like
which married to the same woman for 60
20 K come on
yet Hobbiton I've gone from aisle to
aisle um what else was the end he's been
in many things I saw him throughout my
entire life yes he's in Brazil Brazil
the ass [ __ ] he's in Time Bandits yeah
he played a Napoleon in time man he
played Peter Pan in the 78 BBC
miniseries The Lost Boys in the world
Shakespeare Company he was in Fellowship
of the Ring and the return of the king
and the hobbits and whatever but also he
was King wasn't what you say that's
right he was The Fifth Element he was
the priest he's King John in Robin and
Marion with Sean Connery [ __ ] loved
that movie
wait so he was the bad guy that's a good
flick although it took me a minute to
remember that he was the bad guy
I got to rewatch it Robin and Marion is
good miss Sean Connery playing old Robin
Hood and [ __ ] [ __ ] Hepburn plain old
Maid Marian yep very bittersweet ending
mmm but it's pretty dope it's like Butch
and Sundance the later years like the
last ride yeah this guy that's a good
movie [ __ ] I'm gonna go watch it tonight
he played the father of Victor
Frankenstein in Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein he played the nasty
restaurateur in big night that's right
he was in big night he's in night falls
in Manhattan Fifth Element
and Zach Braff's father in golden in
Garden State I didn't say that's right
yeah my god what a huge storied career
here and there's a whole nother [ __ ]
list because the dude made like a
hundred and forty movies but let's say
the fixer oh what a lovely war Mary
Queen of Scots
juggernaut Greystoke The Legend of
Tarzan lord of the Apes can read the
fifth Hamlet Naked Lunch madness of King
George lifeless ordinary Joe Gould
Secret The Aviator and
strangers with candy and he voiced the
grumpy chef Skinner in ratatouille Oh
get out of here the one who was they
tied up and they throw him in the fridge
and [ __ ] yeah the one who's always
trying to get it like honey was right
when he tastes it he goes like this and
he loved it he was mad that's a good
[ __ ] movie um Wow I yeah I mean he's
he was and he's like the the cartilage
of a lot of flicks right he really is
and you know as a Royal Shakespeare
Company veteran like he just ended up
being that classy dude that you would
hire it's like hey we're making the
science fiction movie it's kind of small
nobody else knows who anybody else is
but we're coming class up the joint and
play a [ __ ] Android yeah I'll come
and do that it's true man he was he was
the first Android before Bishop it was
ash ash yeah so here's the one that put
his fake head on the table and he was
spitting stuff yeah yeah I mean it's
it's how old he was holy [ __ ] yes I mean
it's no 20,000 people but like that's
getting close to 90 yeah you know Joel
Schumacher was not a commander the
British Empire nor a knight and yet Sir
Ian Holm was of both he got eight more
years he did and by all means he used
him well he's been acting in the last
like it I imagine acting up to the end
um I think there was some what did it
say I feel like I just saw him in
something fairly recently yeah I mean
it's it's he hadn't been dormant for
very long but I think he passed away
from complications I think was
Parkinson's another guy who told the
stories we were kid [ __ ] man our whole
childhoods passing before our eyes I
mean I guess that's the the penalty for
getting older is you get to see your
childhood fade yeah [ __ ] yeah moments
like that then I'm like I wish I hadn't
lived through the heart attack you watch
other people [ __ ] pass away people
that you think are like more talented
than you people who like like all that
sound like dude was living life right
moments like this I wish I slept with
nineteen thousand four hundred twenty
three doubles so back back that's crazy
I'm honestly like gonna go
time isn't it is 9:38 we leaving very
soon to go do celebrity show off on 10
10 o'clock on TBS but before that
happens I'm gonna stop in real quick and
say to my wife do you know how many
people told Schumacher supposedly had
sex with that will blow her mind first
thing she'll say is like we're not doing
it 20 thousand times
yeah really something to shoot for
one of the news we got can we race
through really quickly dad to see all
those people go it's a [ __ ] bummer
absolutely god damn death look here's my
hot take [ __ ] death moving [ __ ] death
real quick JK Simmons is not done
apparently playing Jenna Dana Jamison
he's gonna play Jay jonah Jameson for a
while right uh he says that he is he's
already shot one film in which he
appears as Jay jonah Jameson and there's
plans for yet another so hopefully he
will continue doing it now and forever
like cats I love that it was such a nice
surprise and far from home when he
popped and that movie was so satisfying
and then like you know they're done and
they're just about to stick the landing
you're like right on I wonder what the
next movie will be like then all sudden
they're like in the next movie he gets
[ __ ] yeah he gets jobs
sorry strong he's gonna suck for him now
I thought we'd see him graduate he's
into life and not so much no [ __ ] yeah
I'm happy to have my expectations
subverted Disney is helping to support
theaters who are opening I guess
imminently even last week the next week
by making a bunch of catalog titles
available to distributors including some
which haven't been in theaters for
decades for example Empire Strikes Back
oh [ __ ] yes which you haven't been able
to see on a big screen since the 97
theatrical releases I mean they just put
out Jurassic Park right I saw the
Jurassic Park was number one this
weekend yeah yeah like it's like 1990
[ __ ] three or four all over again so
maybe that's the secret to getting
people prime prime the pump for people
to go see Tennant to go see Wonder Woman
and stuff is to dangle pretty pearls
from their childhood in front of
you know they're definitely gonna try
cuz they're letting the Avengers Empire
Strikes Back Black Panther I would go
all three of those Deadpool Zootopia
greatest showman Ironman oh hold on
Zootopia I would go to a greatest
showman I'd watch it home what's after
that ah
Ironman first one yep I would totally go
watch that on a big screen or so we can
inside out and that's force awakens and
inside out yeah inside out I could watch
at home I like that movie but like I
don't need to go see the big screen but
Empire Strikes Back
[ __ ] Iron Man those are good calls
yeah I mean who knows I mean there was
this story are they giving him two movie
theaters for free probably not but you
know it's still like you have wait oh
she way cheap you know including stuff
like you know Empire which you hadn't
been able to program in a theater unless
we're legit rip house for a long time
right and I know there were talked to a
lot of rep houses while I was on tour
with Jay and Silent Bob reboot and they
were like they didn't like that Disney
bought Fox because they started taking
prints out of circulation so at least
sounds like they're coming back in a
little few of them are coming back into
circulation yeah and the last quick news
story is there was a horror movie that
was filmed on zoom for no budget that
for a brief and shining moment was
number one at the box office
what's it called yeah it's yeah now it's
called untitled I believe No unsubscribe
excuse me subscribe it was shot on Zoom
the movie from a bunch of actors and
novice filmmakers five youtubers during
a video conference call and then like
murder shows up but they basically
four-walled it where they bought out one
theater and they bought all the tickets
themselves and so $25,000 was enough to
get number one in a box office it's so
smart and like so smart you know what my
hats off to those kids you game the
system kids a smart tilt the table
because it's tilted in their favor so if
I can do whatever you can man that's
smart that's cool man that's it whatever
they do next they can say we were the
number one movie our movie was number
one the box office so [ __ ] smart and
for the low low cost of how much 25
grand they like it probably cost some
more to buy out the theater than to make
the movie
I mean they know money they spent no
money making the movie think it's true I
don't know [ __ ] Zoom call and then
essentially they're like well if we buy
out theater it's kind of like a party
anyway and then also buck themselves
literally bought themselves a place in
history
yeah that's legit it's not like yeah you
can't put an asterisk next to it it's
like look they [ __ ] put the movie in
theaters and it made money and that's
how we do these charts and number one
there it is I mean that's cool that's
120 we'll get an asterisk as a year yeah
but that that particular step is totally
legit I can't I feel [ __ ] stupid for
not thinking of that myself I love
gaming the system stuff we did it with
reboot and for some weird little records
but I should have [ __ ] I should take
reboot out like it just put it on a
couple screens I can take clerks ad buy
it out I mean it can go out I don't own
it what do I own [ __ ] I don't know
anything that's the problem have you
done have you investigated drive-ins yes
you could do it strikes back
reboot double feature yeah we have
investigated drive-ins and right now
drive-ins are it's tough to get a screen
because there it's the biggest game in
town and so you know the it's very much
like and I ain't taking anything away
from drive-ins they're wonderful and
they've you know but for years they've
been hanging on this is their [ __ ]
moment so it's also their moment to
negotiate like you know you could go
I've spoken to drive-ins that are like
yeah the cut is 60 40 60 us for to you
and it's like oh I understand like
that's a substantial using the whole
fist down yeah you know and I get it
it's like take advantage while you can
and you know they can't have as many
cars in as possible but so it's their
moment so because we were at one point
fishing around about doing something but
it became like expensive essentially
we're not not expensive it's just you're
not making really anything they are
which good for them but they don't need
me to do that they've got other typical
doing it but yeah I did look into it
that's so [ __ ] smart God what is it
called
unsubscribe unsubscribe and so is it
available also online or know it can be
rented through Vimeo oh [ __ ] are you
kidding me how old are these kids
unclear
it doesn't necessary years old yeah
that's good that's some good news to go
out on makes me happy man yeah good for
them and everybody should be thinking
about doing that right now
have you ever wanted a box office record
now at this time man it's like going to
a bug in like convenience store and
getting your name on a keychain like you
can get it too if you try out you can
literally run a camera on your [ __ ]
family for like 75 minutes that's the
length of a feature film rent out a
theater for 25 grand widen from the
number one movie in the country about
your family yes you know it's like it
the best going-away present look what we
did for you you're a box-office star
biggest sports integra was in the 80s
you can open a movie at number one your
Will Smith do you could literally think
about it this is the only time in
history where with enough money you
could pay to be Will Smith big at the
box office
25k I'll get you there wow that's [ __ ]
dope man still in terms of numbers of
20k that 25k is impressive the other 20k
hot damn I'm not gonna sleep tonight cuz
I'm just gonna be sitting there rolling
over in my head the map over and over
and over again my wife's gonna be like
why are you thinking about men having
sex in bed and I'm like cuz 20,000 is a
lot and it indicates a good review like
you know what I'm saying like it's like
it's so exhausting
like no wonder he was he was always in
shape you have to be he's like an
ultra-marathoner but for like a doesn't
do to show everyone gave him [ __ ] for
Batman but he was Iron Man and I am I
can do this all day yeah you can
and work work on set we'll miss you Joel
yes well we'll miss you Denny we'll miss
you mr. Ian home and we'll miss you the
audience we're gonna miss a cue and eggs
I'm I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here go
watch a celebrity show off I had to
remember the name yes on TBS and we just
put up the second like episode of Sun
and lockdown which is my little show and
we just put up on YouTube tonight where
they put up on YouTube tonight so you
can see the second part sooner or later
I may get kicked off the show but while
we're there you know it's fun charity
and stuff fun thing and I get to work
with my family so anyway I'm gonna go
talk about that right now yes online my
god what a great world we live in I know
nobody is saying that right now but that
Michael Keaton news is pretty impressive
yeah for these past 70 minutes it's been
a pretty decent world yeah good luck
dealing with the real world after this
if you got to go back into it and stuff
they don't seem to care as much about
Michael Keaton who big Batman you know
the disease it's taken us all and stuff
like that numbers are spiking - I know
we're saying this while we're standing
very close and whatnot but make sure you
and I know we're saying this and we're
not wearing masks but make sure your
mask on wear your mask yeah wash your
hands where your masked a six feet away
not over just because you want it to be
over it's not and a lot of people are
like oh the second waves beginning
apparently we're still in the first wave
so yeah it hasn't gone down yet it has
and it's only going up so be careful out
there and stuff that's what Joel
Schumacher said I was gonna say respect
the man but that is respect there it is
ladies and gentlemen joyed yourselves
there is no show or dirty double
entendres without band to my left I've
it up with a great mark barnard no thank
you thank you so much that is fat man
beyond for this week ladies and
gentlemen tune in next week same fad
time same fat channel SModcast com
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith mr. mom
as Batman is back peace love chicken
grease No